okay well four people joining the live
stream this is one of a series of
meetings on language completeness and
consistency full of language okay so
this is about the function information
which is a general function for giving
information about objects and for some
strange reason I'm okay so do we have
people from design here we should leave
these here these here and and there are
two sorts of issues I think what we see
here is only going to sort of deal with
one of them oh this isn't the the most
up-to-date version yeah let me send that
to you yeah I think I put around it okay
so what's the visual way to the second
point which is undocumented function
file information recently and what does
it do and how does it so it's a it's a
thing way you can give it a string and
it will give you a similar information
books about the file is that right right
and I was thinking we're not going to
have any new information new information
things and I think it would just be
informational file of the string right
yeah and I did send that right link but
it looks like Heidi has updated the
mock-up with more examples of it
so listen I think okay so what's the
below the fold above the fold type thing
um right so if you have a prototype
build you can see what it looks like now
and we certainly have we do have openers
I'm not sure there was sort of a
question of if we want to have and above
and below the fold system do we want
there to be some priority in determining
what properties are there do we just
show the first few of them because
normally they're going to be sorted
roughly by relevance or at least by what
well your point is you're asking for
information you know you should get it
why you below the fold above the folding
I agree with that you didn't say that
but I'm I'm agreeing with that okay yeah
and the visuals here the the fourth
mock-up or the the final one final
column is the closest what we currently
have but adds a little bit of extra
detail and Heidi had also looked at some
other options to try and bold some of
the particular information we have you
know if there's musically a primary
really ugly
I mean having no structure there it just
doesn't doesn't cut it for me they don't
think we have you know unique colors
necessarily I wouldn't be recommending
that either I would be recommending I
like a default generic gray for anything
less important okay so that's America
yeah third and fifth both had no color
yeah third I see design Mach three here
looks like her house if you scroll down
what's wait a man I'm quite liking three
here yes different instances of the same
of the same mock-up so each column is
different instances of the same design
for 14 in the variation here being that
some types like functions or data bins
or entity types may have the first field
with a different color that's associated
with those particular things so the
yellow but this heading here says usage
and it shouldn't it should say function
if it's gonna say anything or symbol
yeah and this is this isn't right this
isn't the correct thing because that's
the UUID which is specific this is
confused I'm sorry right this is this is
because this thing needs to be labeled
right mm-hmm and I think this is really
ugly having this double gutter II thing
here right but that's not but the
problem is you've got to label this
because we could put a heading at the
top of the whole thing that says what it
is namely you know built-in symbol I
don't think that would be a bad thing to
do in the making sense or symbol or
something recommend symbol you know they
have been etc so do you think in terms
of the the primary banner the design
moth 1b you know there's a little extra
bit of header there that we'd probably
get rid of in place of
the the the blue color and and being
there below you know below usage right
is that we write another one of our
design goals is to sort of merge four
symbols for which there already is an
information you know merge the
appearance of the usage you get from
information with you know this new
information so right so I you know we're
going to use to blue only we're you know
only at the very top where it says more
symbol then I suppose we could have you
know question mark and double question
mark use some special mode where this
plays differently okay okay look look
look the plot point is we either had a
bar that says what kind of a thing it is
okay that header bar shouldn't be
terribly emphasized I think the level of
emphasis that we're seeing in design
Mach three is good for that okay I think
the thing where we have a color block
there that is nice for this although I
don't know if we're always going to end
up with a big I mean gosh you know I
think there's an argument that the
identifying elements whether it's the
bin ID no not a good idea okay look the
top bar should be the category of thing
it is there can be color for the first
entry if that makes any sense
am I making sense then but every entry
has to be labeled and I don't see how to
do the labeling of that color first
entry without and this is not right to
put the usage thing I think that's ugly
there
um got what I'm saying this is gonna
work here you're lined with the rest of
the column makes it a little awkward
he's gonna join us in a minute here go
ahead yeah I mean depending on what well
I mean we could make some number of
these guys magic right for example
symbols and entities who get the color
thing with no label and then for generic
things we have look look the things we
need every line needs to be labeled like
the UID needs to be labeled and so on so
could we please see a mock-up where it
has a heavier gray bar at the top here
followed by I wish we didn't have so
much background noise I don't know who's
generating that and it's very
distracting um I think that's the wind
blowing against window I'm skeptical but
anyway never mind it not that you can't
do anything but that's the cause of that
together noise when it's windy okay it's
okay
in any case um so I think it's got to be
that slightly heavier gray a title at
the top every line is identified and
then the only question is for the case
of a symbol like this I think we treat
and for that case which we know to be a
special case we do not label the usage
but we simply do this for that to go
what I'm saying mm-hmm
for other cases we you know they're
pretty boring anyway and we just have
the header bar because we don't have
narrative text for and most of these
others right right I mean it may be that
some of like the machine learning things
well I don't know we can look at that
but but I they may have pictures and
things but I think we have the
possibility of a distinguished thing
that might have even a color background
so in this case here where we say file
and then file type that's a bit goofy
because it's going to say file at the
top mm-hmm well it would be named or
pass yeah right exactly
um so okay I think this is reasonable I
don't know what we do for the entities
and whether we go anything particularly
interesting for them I mean we could
make the the header bar yellow in that
case
but we're not gonna say entity type
we're gonna say well okay some of these
cases we move the okay we say we could
say country entity and have that be
yellow right in other words the header
bar in that case could be non generic in
the sense that it's using information
about what type of entity it is it could
also be colored mm-hmm and I think my
expectation for like entity would be
that you know the type and the name
would be sort of flipped in that
representation you have sort of the
Spain in the yellow block and type
country underneath but yeah let's see
what it looks like in that way I don't
think these icons are adding anything I
think we should not do them okay I think
Jeremy Davis joined does he have any
comment same here yeah as treaties I
don't think the icons are doing much um
so is the plan to still have the title
in the dark grey that's generic it's the
type basically yeah it's the type except
in this case here where I think we
should say country entity okay
you
or just country why not just country and
this would say here cloud object right
yeah and this here would say data bin
I'm not sure why you say some credence
that entity it could get us into trouble
in some domains like for mathematical
functions where if the title just says
Mathematica function you may think it's
referring to a symbol when it's actually
referring to a mathematical function or
mathematics down but that's why it's a
yellow mm-hm
okay says slightly unconvincing way yes
so are you proposing then alright so
you're proposing that we say entity at
the top in the gray bar and then in the
yellow we say Spain what we could do is
we could show whatever whatever we
normally do Spain paren country whatever
we normally do in the entity specifier
yes I think that's a solution for this
oops what enough happens here okay that
was an interesting bug that was an
interesting bug by the way that's worth
reporting dynamic updating was was not
on and when I kept typing it went
outside of the yeah okay so I think it
could look like the disembodied version
of this without all of its orange
bordering mm-hmm okay okay we have a
source from that there may be some other
cases to worry about but I think this is
basically going to work the second
question that we think about is and so
in evaluate question mark Rockstar right
so there's also this case and so I think
this is rather magnificent except that
it needs a little bit of design tweaking
right and there is a second so are you
saying that in this case we should
basically reproduce this friend's
appearance so is that supposed to be
equivalent to information of plots dawn
yes
but I'm not sure what if anything it
currently does at the moment the same
thing yeah within within the normal
release kernel that's what it does if
you in the prototype version because we
don't want information to be side effect
heavy it will it is a very rough
approximation of this where it basically
goes through and and creates an actual
output that has the same info so there's
a wrapper around it right now but it
produces the side effects when you click
on them and what we were thinking is
that probably when you click on those
you should get the information pod that
you would get if you look up that symbol
and what we want yeah yeah you that
thing there yeah okay it is the quick
sorry go ahead
yeah so there's a little bit about the
visuals right we could like make that
great background:transparent and so then
it would look like the currents
information or if we want to tweak that
some other way and then the question is
should clicking on this you know spawn
off and you back when information was
printing a side effect
you know I say the Fed printing it made
sense for this to be a separate cell the
question is you know was this one or
should this provide some interface
that's which is to look for and
at the end za'darius I'm thinking I'm
thinking I think it should make a I
think probably that link should spawn
should sell print a new cell that is one
of these boxes okay
now whether it overwrites I'm not sure
right now it's overwriting right as
opposed to generating the whole sequence
of this thing then this thing then this
thing I have to say I think it might be
more useful to generate the sequence
rather than do the overwrite I mean that
case is one that's true in my personal
use I generally like the right anybody
else have an opinion
perhaps if is there is a way to go back
to the original cell so that you can
click somewhere else oh no no no
overwrite in the following sense look if
I press plot region it's gonna overwrite
what was here you see then you can just
click on the first first thing again
then overwrite again and restore the
previous right all right let's believe
it is over right yeah if it were to keep
adding cells that would be great until
you click 15 and then you keep all right
extrusion is bad okay fine that's over
right um okay I'm not too bothered about
the so printing now in terms of the look
of this creature you know this is a
fairly special case
I think the way that the contexts are
handled could be a little better okay
I mean it's not terrible but I think it
could be a little better now is it I
mean if I do this we'll probably get a
much bigger output
I see
and if you create a symbol p.m. global
and right than the Stirling Castle well
this is basically quite nice I mean I I
don't really have a problem with this
the only question is whether the design
sort of style is appropriate for what we
have for the rest of it Heidi and Jeremy
comments on that that blue is a little
much
and they tone it back a little bit it
just seems a little overwhelming but you
know it's not horrible
okay what about what about the way these
arrows work and things and what about
some I think those would be more
naturally in a bar at the top of some
kind like documentation that makes sense
so the whole kind of bar would be
clickable yeah well more like this I
suppose more like those bars but yeah
okay from our live students discussion
it would look nice to nest panels for
sub package contexts
just an idea I mean remember these have
to be publicly visible contexts on the
day a pattern they're also fine I've it
back take P star it's gonna get all
kinds of random junk what would this
look like if it was nested in some way
right then I guess you would have a
really utilities bar or I see then dude
that would be nice actually
that would be nice I think that's a
luxury item but I think it would be nice
and maybe that in the terms of the
design you could try and work something
up that would deal with that in a
sensible way I use this as your example
I do use - lets go um yeah I think that
would help now yeah and I like these the
way these openness closes work as a way
to sort of navigate this pile of
information so minor tweaks to this but
otherwise think we're good here I don't
really think the line printer
you know alternating colors of line
printer paper necessarily does nothing
for me well I mean okay well maybe maybe
it's a good idea Johnny the whole
thing's a little much for me I'd like to
tone it back maybe the lines toning back
or going away but you know I think it
needs to be toned back a little bit okay
right now it seems kind of noisy fine
okay I think that
it for this item unless anybody has
anything else it I everything else on
this
I don't think so Nick you know that
pretty much answers all the remaining
questions I had so we'll work on great
okay information here we come
all right so people who are involved
just in that part of this discussion can
drop off thank you all soon okay bye-bye
okay next up sorting function
right so there was this idea from Danny
which you said seemed interesting but
instead of sorting function we had
sorted by which I actually liked to do
so yeah it's a little weird what's an
example where we'd be using this like
eigenvalues or something sorted by
whatever it's a little cutesy
I mean faces is the consumer okay the
question is whether we sort youth before
beauty or something we don't really have
Beauty but we can have youth before we
can sort by increasing youth or
decreasing youth can we please cut out
the background noise um okay no there's
noise coming from outside my office okay
okay okay I'm sorry I'd um I still think
sorting functions sounds more
appropriate
and I feel like there going to be some
special cases of sorting function that
are going to be named sorting functions
which is why I'm not so keen on having
an explicit sorted by and then giving a
function name
so my tendency is to say we should
continue with sorting function the point
is sorted by was to remove that
ambiguity between the by and the not by
sorting stuff I know
I don't know and it comes from other
people I do like assaulted by I like
sorted by alright let's let's try doing
sorted by okay okay alright let's go on
to a rule right so this was a thread
well the 2-way rule should be supported
in replace well yes stream replace
replace family of functions right now
clearly when there are patterns it's
kind of a complicated situation I mean
if we're saying replace if we say you
know ABC slash dot you know exchange a
with C that's kind of cute
right that seems very nice to be able to
do that but now less obvious is what to
do and I say we should support I think
that's a nice piece of syntactic and
it's gonna make some nice-looking code
um now the question is if this is
instead you know F of a F of B G of C
slash dot F blank
exchange with G blank
can that mean something well I have an
even simpler example for you and by the
way this is hopeless because we don't
know what to bind the blanks to do we I
mean this is exactly what happens in the
when we're doing the theorem proving
stuff when we have these two-way
transformations and and how have we done
that in the theorem proving case Jose
can you comment on that so that you
don't remember what do you mean okay so
here's what I mean
ya see here we've got I see so
everything's been one-way a five by the
way this function should have the the
big examples rather than having to go to
proof object for all the examples but
that's a different story if you couldn't
make that comment to Jonathan that would
be helpful I don't know whether we want
to copy over all the examples but we
needs to need more examples in this
function itself Jose did that make sense
and I moved confused so you want more
properties of the results oh yeah I want
to be able to show how you get yes I
want to be able to show with a sub value
immediately equational find equational
proof of blob sub sub value you know
proof graph and so on I mean we can show
more actual results here we sit because
this is the main workhorse function
that's doing things not proof object
which is really just having things
access to and I think we should move the
bulk of the examples and to find
equational proof and outs of proof
object see what I'm saying yes okay I
see a thing yes yes okay but the point
that I'm making here is I don't even
know how any of this stuff works I mean
this is f of G of X blank goes to f of X
but isn't that also one that goes the
other way around or has it been resolved
into being one direction or the other by
now at the Romans has been a very soft
so what my start provides the direction
in which it should go
okay okay okay so that's been resolved
but at the beginning I see here what
we're doing is we're purely giving we're
not using patterns to represent the
two-way equivalences yeah okay
anyway it's how you were going to give
me another horror case sorry so I think
Danny has a bear with a be exchange yeah
basically where your cursor is a B goes
to a right so if let's see if I can
generate an example in real time right
but basically what if you have write a
case where something gets turned in
right where it matters of whether you do
the left the left-to-right exchange
first or the rights left yes I
understand
well we can define that I mean and also
it's a question of how Slashdot
recursively descends through the
expression because this if the
expression is a comma a B comma you know
a a B or something like this well that's
a bad example let's put another brace in
there um
right which one should it see the hole a
be first or should it see the a first
and turn that into an a B in which case
what does it do them well it's it's now
touched it so for that part of the slash
dots are the usual rules of slash dot it
should do nothing it makes sense Cynthia
should be always equivalent to left goes
to the right and then comma the right
goes to the left
okay that's a very reasonable point of
view so in that case what we would be
saying is this thing slash dot left goes
to right right goes to left okay so what
does that do
okay
dandy that's fine I mean it's perfect a
sensible result okay so the issue is
only with pattern variables then right
hmm well what are the choices we could
give an error
think there's anything useful to do
right and you know I don't think we have
any patterns that take other patterns
that only take literals maybe I'm just
not thinking the point but it's a little
weird to introduce something that only
works with literals it's it is a little
weird but I mean you know the fact is if
anybody thinks about it they'll realize
why it can't work with patterns and most
of the time people will try this for
literals because that's the case where
it works but worked with named patterns
right right the f was a underscore left
right arrow G of a underscore because
that just expands out into right that
would be the same basically as f goes to
G except that that except only one
Athens your heads we don't generally
have patterns on right sides of rules oh
sorry
yeah I'm being I'm being silly Yeah
right it's only it binds the name and
the knee I and listen I think we should
do this and just generate a message if
the thing has patterns in it say only
possible with literals
anybody object I think that's what we
should do I like it I think it's a nice
and useful thing and I think it's a
convenient shorthand for as Jose says
it's equivalent to one rule than the
other I'll tell you what let's look at
what actually happens ok so here's I
mean what's gonna happen is if we do
this let's let's see what it actually
does okay and you're gonna get literals
literal patterns yeah
you know if the right thing for G of AI
underscore F of a underscore
and you already get a message yes crying
this is just fine you can you can expand
it the exact same way yeah I mean use
Jose's rule and then the message is full
whether chips fall so to speak all right
let's go it's a quick question at the
risk of yeah irritating eta do we also
want to extend this to replace part
where you say replace part something and
then position to a rule position and
have it will start really weird it's
cute but really weird so you're saying -
I mean that's just weird if I might say
so that's fundamentally changing yeah I
think it's it's a little crazy but it's
an interesting operation
it's a swapping operation we've never
needed that operation in all these years
was this affirmative oration
yes prefers well and so in fact we do
have permute which we actually have it
so these would be cycles just to see
just me that's what I would think I mean
it's very notice supported transpose so
there's no reason why that you work in
permute this seems sensible to me
right yeah where else do we have
reversible operations like this well
anything that takes cycles so that's
flat or actually take cycles or only
takes that notation flooding doesn't
take permutations okay but only
something reversible what about some of
the array flattened type things that
where they go for particular levels and
so on
not clear okay let's let's move on if we
can that's a good that's a good point
about penuche all right caching as
opposed to suppressing repeated error
messages so this is something that I
think is pretty crazy I guess the one
thing that's perhaps not completely
crazy is I mean we do have ways to sort
of internal ways of dealing with
messages as they arise that they're not
really document there than something
there let's remind us what the issue is
the issue is that there might be a
thousand error messages we are
displaying only the first three and
somebody wants to see the whole you know
collection of all the error messages is
that right what caller could call it
methodology somebody wants to do some
kind of message analytics on this whole
collection of messages rather than just
seeing the first three right he wants
yeah he doesn't want them to all appear
at once for one thing that would or I
guess would appear continuously because
that was from them once well whatever I
can I can generate um that's a change to
see to I and iterate over all right so
the
general stop um from 30 years ago is
still with us and now what we can do
here so the issue is with this we can do
show a stack trace it so very Joey how
often do you guys using that I mean I
find myself using it occasionally using
what the stack trace I use it regularly
good about to say is I know you guys are
special cases and I find it right I find
that the stack trace always contains
exactly two things the outermost
expression and the thing and you know
the bad thing and no stack in between
and so I don't find it useful right okay
okay but so the main question here is if
we generated all you know would it be
useful to see kind of the analytics of
all ten of these things and the answer
is probably yes and so the issue is what
you definitely don't want is all these
things spewing into the front end right
so what would be nice in modern times
and certainly was not conceivable back
in 1987 when this was designed is if
down here you could see something that
went you know log ten times or something
you know if this could aggregate itself
and say and ten more of the same
which is what this is almost saying but
not quite now in principle it could be
dynamic in the sense that as you know
what you could be seeing in a perfect
world what you could be seeing is a
thing that says ten more of the same 11
12 13 14 et cetera with that number
dynamically changing
is there a way of generating how do I
get that list of messages can I just say
messages of I'm not not the quiet at
once I mean there isn't a document that
very complete the private messages
they're internal ways what am I doing
here
do I think messages is giving you
messages associated with so what is the
a think you want dollar message trust
yeah right I don't use this but I need
it right but it needs to be part of the
evaluation so if you have it as part of
a combo with the name with the do rate
right okay so you can tell I haven't
used this very much um so you know to my
mind having better message analytics for
example being able to see that a
particular message is like counting up
the number of times it's being a student
things will be nice and being able to
get sort of the summary you know the
data structure that represents the names
of the messages like this will be nice
would be nice there are a lot of quieted
messages right I mean there are quite a
few if somebody who you know wants the
debugger and sometimes puts messages and
like basically every evaluation second
third and fourth Dan you can't you can't
for that cuz general stop kicked in
right right I how soon I forget in any
case the the but explicitly quieted
messages are different from one from
stopped messages are we're not talking
about quieted messages here we're
talking about stopped messages now I
don't know whether the internal
mechanism happens to be the same for
those two cases
don't think it is right so we're only
talking about displaying stopped
messages I agree it's a complete
ridiculous you know you're going way too
deep in the kind of worms if you're
going to look at all quieted messages
right so so Jeremy when you film set up
a message handler can you tell the
difference between quieted messages and
stop messages I mean it may be internal
that's you can only do that and see I
don't know I don't think so but I'm not
sure that I've actually tried it okay
wait wait let's assume that there is a
way maybe the hook doesn't exist right
now to get the stopped messages then
what would we do with the stop messages
the idea would be to have a rich you
know version of this output including
for example account for the number of
each message I don't know what else will
be useful I mean would it be useful to
have a word cloud of what messages
occurred I don't know please dancer eat
I question the the handler actually
doesn't realize that the message is
being suppressed okay that's interesting
mmm what do you mean the handle which
handler so the handler so can I get the
stopped messages out somehow or not
there is an internal way of doing that
yes okay fine just does it did not get
the general stop message or does it see
it also it also sees the general stop
message so I guess your point is that
you can you can capture the general stop
message and that way you can figure out
that being issued and is not quieted but
won't appear
right okay fine fine okay so then the
question is what would we like to
display if we could display it right
I mean what do people think would be
useful would it be useful to see for
example would it be useful to see a
dynamic thing in which there's a um just
a second excuse me sorry I'm asked to go
soon um but but here's a thing you know
because when we originally designed this
mechanism we didn't have any kind of
dynamic output um and the you know
another possibility would be to have a
dynamic thing where you can see messages
flashing by or is that crazy
I would be in that for most people that
would be quite distracting as a as a nun
default behavior I mean just a single
line of your car you know a ticker-tape
so to speak
let's imagine there was a single line
ticker tape of messages I would
personally pick at your house disappear
that kind of stuff makes my eyes go
bonkers anyway what is what what is okay
by the way on the live stream somebody's
asking whether no difference in warnings
and errors define morning define error
they determine whether Emacs or V is
superior it's the same I've reduced it
to the same to a different religious war
no I mean I think that there are I mean
do we believe that there are cases in
which we have what amount to you know
fatal errors but we've talked about this
endlessly we've talked about this it
seems to be essentially impossible to
solve because one person's error is
another person's warning and another you
know etc but okay so the question is
what I mean can somebody summarize this
thread
Jeremy you're the most active
participant in this thread so I
volunteer you yeah so other life
students commenting warning is something
that displays an error but the
computation returns something the
problem is all of our computations
return something if it returns an
evaluate 'add because you know Zeta of
three returns unev al you ated but it's
not an error
but I mean it's a very hard thing to
define um okay in a case sorry we
summarized the thread yeah so what
happened here was this person had this
problem with a whole bunch of insert
statements that were happening as part
of a looper or just as part of one
program and so general stop kicked in
but this person because each message is
different it would have actually have
been interesting to see each individual
message and not have the general stop
kick in well that's an interesting
algorithmic issue because the question
is okay so that's interesting because
one could imagine general sculpt only
kicking in you know for example having a
different heuristic if the text is
different see what I'm saying so
let's imagine that this was log cold
with three four five arguments get what
I'm saying right the prot the problem is
all you have to do is have changed this
from log called with three arguments to
log of a B I was called with three
arguments and of course now I is the one
two three four and now it's actually
looking like ten different messages when
it's really the same well is that the
case that I mean how often do we repeat
the content in the message
it depends on the message mm-hmm well we
cannot repeat the content except I mean
okay so a claim would be if we repeat
the content then the content is worth
seeing and then my position is the
content is always worth seeing because
if I'm doing a whole bunch of sums of a
whole bunch of products of a whole bunch
of logs telling me that one of the logs
and my giant expression was wrong I find
really unhelpful I want to know which of
my logs was called with the wrong
arguments and so I actually wants to see
the full log expression and not just
that so an interesting quote but doesn't
that doesn't that show up in the stack
trace well so what you're arguing for
which is an interesting possibility is
that in addition to the stack trace in
the dot dot we should have a thing that
says show the expression that generated
this which we certainly have right I
mean which is the top of the stack trace
at some level all right some level right
actually it's not the top of the site
it's the second thing down in the stack
trace or or more yeah depending on
exactly how this was implemented and
what yen
Goethe really that right right but only
only because the internals of log have
been excised from the stack trace know
the thing right before the message is
generated will be the thing that
generates the message
put I in a private context
you
Varian dramatical well you need both of
them in might literally need a private
in it
oh it's gonna do some kind of crazy
thing okay fine
all right it's gonna stick all right
listen I think I have to go
unfortunately this is a good topic I
think what we need to do I mean there's
a general question of kind of how to
think about what what else would we like
to get out of messages so one thing is
the expression that generated the error
that seems like a very worthwhile thing
to have and rather easy to add the dot
dot another is the possibility of of
stopping only upon really boring you
know on a lot of you know to similar
messages so to speak and then the other
thing would be essentially message
analytics of showing you know how many
messages came out like for example at
the end after further output will be
suppressed we could have a thing saying
general so to speak log RCT generated
311 times because we know that don't we
at the end before the thing returns we
could say generated 311 times
right
it was needed and they were but what I
was going to say like that lost of a
little in that sentence so what I'm
saying is in this case we actually know
at the end that log argh T was generated
ten times right we could say that
somewhere further output was suppressed
and then we could say log you know
general logs CT or you know some other
type of message cell we're saying log AG
T was generated ten times or something
right and that will be useful because
you could see for example it would
occasionally be useful to see okay
that's three hundred eleven of those and
315 of those personally interesting to
me is you know was it five times or was
five hundred times if it's five times I
might want to turn off general stop and
see all five messages
by the way do we have a way to turn off
general scope yes no I understand that
but in here we should have a way to do
it here yeah I know but we should have a
special case for the general stop
message because it's very obscure to say
turn off this message to have the other
messages come out generally what to say
oh I see tit for each message say don't
general stop this message well no I
meant turn off log T don't have it turn
off the turning off of that message
right I mean so the other thing that
occurred to me is that occasionally you
know it would be useful for me is the
general stop is fine but I'd be fine
with it kicking in after the first
message yes but that's luxury yes yes
exactly
okay listen listen for the next time we
discussed this let's get some buggy code
to look at to so that we actually have
some decent examples of complicated
message you know Cascades and so on okay
and then let's some I think we can do
you know I think this whole dark
mechanism that we invented a couple
years ago has been really nice I think
we should you know generalize from that
and come up with some other things and
I'm sorry we haven't been able to do the
register catch thing because I know
that's important yeah although we should
you know definitely try to get the
boilerplate code that Jeremy asked for
on that I don't know what that is okay I
have got to run thank you all thanks to
folks on the live stream see y'all soon